je l'ai trouvé devant ma porte un soir
que je rentre chez moi partout elle me
faites escorte elle est revenue elle est
là la renifleuse des seins moments elle
m'a suivi pas à pas la gare que le
diable l'emporte les revenus elle est là
avec sa gueule de carême avec ses larges
yeux cernés elle nous fait le cœur à la
traîne elle nous fait le cœur à pleurer
elle nous fait des mains timbler mais de
longue nuit désolé la garce
elle nous ferait même l'hiver en plein
cœur de l'été
la solitude ce qui est incroyable c'est
qu'elle dit la solitude juste à la fin
juste à la fin et pendant toute la
chanson on se demande si c'est qui une
amie une amoureuse une mère